E aí
o lugar de cada um na sociedade é na
verdade um lugar para todos lugar de
todos bom Dentes mais obrigado a Patrick
pelas palavras bonitas que aqui disse
sobre mim e agora vamos todos baixar as
expectativas está bem que eu vou
continuar a falar
e eu devia ter uns 6 7 8 anos eu queria
ser astronauta mas na verdade eu não sei
muito bem porque não sei se é por causa
que estão do espaço nas Estrelas poderia
a lua Mas eu queria mesmo ser astronauta
claramente não sou burro
é mas eu conheço viu o que levou a
escolher outro caminho não foi terem
cortado as hipóteses a partida eu tive
exatamente as mesmas possibilidades
poder ser astronauta como qualquer o
exame estão Mas Sou psicóloga
e na verdade quando nasce não houve um
médico sentado com os meus pais e
dissesse assim nós temos que conversar
sobre a sua filha que ela não tem aqui a
competências para ser astronauta
e talvez psicóloga
e essa conversa não teve fato lar e eu
tive oportunidade os meus caminhos sejam
abertos assim a semelhança de um GPS não
é o Google Maps com os caminhos todos
abertos sem cortar o caminho mais rápido
ao caminho mais curto ou sem
auto-estradas não eu disse todas as
possibilidades para poder fazer o que eu
quis e vai entendido também na escola
quando entrei para a escola a professora
não chama novamente os meus pais não
escolhe isso não vai lá ela de facto
astronauta não vai Lar talvez psicóloga
a
a educação de fato depressivo muito
pouco a pessoa trabalhar alguns anos em
escolas e tal como já foi referido com
alunos com necessidades especiais que se
parece que agora também assunto estavam
não se pode ser este ter mas ele facto
existe está bem falamos de crianças com
críticas quando cidade que eu tive
especiais e essência do meu percurso ao
longo dos anos
bom mas se quiser explicar e dizeres o
como é que deve fazer ao como é que deve
intervir ou como é que se deve acreditar
as competências essas crianças se elas
quiserem ser astronautas eu não sei
dizer mas sabes apresentar uma história
e deve de um exemplo de uma criança
essas duas crianças que vocês veem na
imagem tinham na altura da foto 6 anos
estava no 1º ano do 1º ciclo
em uma delas não é relevante qual uma
delas tem perturbação do espectro do
autismo e no início do ano e aquela
confusão normal que nós sabemos uma
escola 1º ciclo barulho tudo a correr e
Muita confusão os entendidos no assunto
portanto professores educadores os
técnicos psicólogos acharam que era
melhor e mais segura criança ficar junto
de auxiliar no portão deixar passar a
confusão Inicial o barulho tudo nós
sabemos que estrutura crianças com
perturbação do espectro do autismo e
depois Sim essa criança ir Acompanhada
pela auxiliar até a sala de aula quando
tivesse tudo sentado
a outra criança a outra crianças de
fazer um bocadinho de confusão não
percebia como é que um amigo não é um
levar seu uma criança como ele próprio
não poderiam ir juntos e entrar naquela
confusão que sugira não é verem fazer
muito barulho e contar o que fizeram dia
anterior e como é que chegaram e fugiram
a saúde e aquilo durante os dias fez
alguma confusão a criança ver o colega
ficar sempre um portão da escola
O que as crianças têm esta capacidade
como nós bem sabemos de olhar para o
quadro e saberem que aquilo não é um
chapéu Aquele é uma cobra que engoliu um
elefante e o fim de uns dias nos quantos
dias da colega ficar no portão da escola
antes fosse chegou Então disse Bom dia
de olho um beijinho calma Malta foi para
o convite está tudo bem descanse em Deus
a mão e seguiram para a sala de aula e
esta imagem eternize este momento
é a partir daqui nunca mais foi
necessário deixar uma criança excluída
no questão da escola mas sim ela pode
ser acompanhada por todos os colegas
passou a ser uma coisa perfeitamente
normal ela ir normalmente para a sala
com os cursos
e eu acho que nós na verdade temos muito
a aprender com as crianças é uma
tendência que me incomoda em particular
que referir que crianças são cruéis
podemos olhar para eles podemos não
teorizar Tudo podemos não complicar
podemos perceber que está uma ovelha
dentro daquela caixa
é importante olhar para este exemplo de
saber que cada um de nós tem um lugar
muito próprio e a semelhança desta
criança pode a minha história qualquer
história que vocês tivessem cortado os
caminhos a partida nós não teríamos tido
a capacidade de explorar eternamente
aquilo que nós queríamos fazer e aqui
não se trata de agarrar né que naquilo
que nós achamos e sabemos em teoria e
sabemos que a a formas de combater a
desigualdade Depois a depois a menores
que nós queremos Na verdade o que nós
queremos não é Caixas mais altas por um
ou caixas mais altas por outros na
verdade o que nós realmente queremos é
retirar todas as barreiras que nós temos
aqui a frente não é e todas as barreiras
que implicam a dificuldade de
transmissão destas crianças
a não ser mais um pormenor Qual é o
objetivo último para qualquer criança
qualquer jovem qualquer aluno que anda
na escola ao longo de pelo menos 12 anos
qualidade e
e eu arrisco dizer e acredito que
qualquer um de vós vai concordar comigo
é torná-los em adultos Independentes
autônomos e seus integrantes de uma
sociedade eu não olhar para as
particularidades ou para as dificuldades
que estão a sentir mas conseguirem
quebrando cada uma destas Barreiras para
que eles possam sim voar alto e fazer eu
querer ou não se a partida consideramos
que alguns jovens não têm capacidade não
tem competência para fazer o que é que
seja então de fácil não vai ter
o meu também arrisco a dizer que nesse
caso nós estamos a fazer o meu trabalho
mas depois também expoentes está à
semelhança das crianças não não mas não
fui eu foi o primeiro mas ele bateu o
primeiro ele já tinha feito aquilo só
que o discurso é diferente né não a
sociedade não está preparada não nós não
temos os recursos humanos que não não
temos não temos dinheiro suficiente não
a família não colabora
não podemos passar a ter o discurso que
nós temos com as crianças quando elas
vem fazer queixinhas e ele foi o
primeiro e fez e foi o meu irmão no fio
e ver o que temos que mudar todo seu
comportamento na verdade nós fazemos
todos parte desta sociedade e esses
crianças que são agora na escola e este
estes jovens que eu agora a estudar que
são formatos independentemente virem a
ser astronautas o psicólogos
independentemente disso a verdade é que
nós temos que aproveitar sempre e
apostar sempre no seu potencial máximo É
verdade também que devemos sempre
apostar que eles possam voar mas voar
muito alto
o e olhar sempre para as características
deles e acima de tudo o que eles querem
não é o que nós queremos enquanto
profissionais não é o que nós queremos
enquanto temos não é o que nos diz a
teoria não é o que dizem as
conceituações todas nós temos
transformadas mas sim como é que nós
podemos fazer diferença e como é que nós
podemos apostar sem vir com o plano já
inscrito não vem
e deu uma folha Branca em que cada um de
nós pode escrever e em que o principal
escritor dessa história é o próprio é o
aluno porque senão também é
responsabilidade de todos mas todos
fazemos todos parte desta sociedade que
tem continuar a dar a dar resposta
e vamos deixá-los voar vamos deixar usar
a ciência do principezinho agarrar os
pássaros e voar para onde quiserem e não
se esqueçam de fato lugar de cada um na
sociedade é na verdade na verdade lugar
todos lugar para todos obrigada a